Hey, what's up?
>> I hounded Dan for quite some time. How
long How many times did that hound you?
>> Like 10.
>> Yeah, about 10.
>> 10 times on signal and on email and in
public groups. Donna, are you coming to
do a presentation? And then prompted.
And he was like, uh, I don't know. I
don't not sure I have enough to say. But
the thing is, I actually prompted him,
well, you're very sensitive to this, to
come and do a vendor pitch.
What? I know you're not doing a vendor
pitch. It's fine. But I hounded him,
come and talk about your company. And
everybody [clears throat] was, what are
you doing, Gaddy? And I went to the
committee and I said, I want to do this.
Because what Dun has done, I did not
mean that pun, but it works. What Dan
has done is essentially create a company
in this space that is not just so-called
AI native but is so ahead of its time
they literally emptied the Apple shops
Apple stores down because they bought
laptops that will be strong enough for
the people stealing your content and yet
everybody start using I think cloth code
right and skills and they keep releasing
their stuff in open source and they
invested millions in getting to the
DARPA acc competition and they have just
made themselves the leaders in many
cases of AI security just because he
took a bet that the world is going to
change. He was did not want to be left
behind. He wanted to actually help make
themselves relevant in the future
because many of us will not be. And that
transformation was so critical for me. I
asked him please come to a vendor pitch.
tell us your journey, your your
transformation of how you see the world
working right now because there is
nobody else out there right now that I
know that can do this both technically
with the right ethos and also be careful
about not pitching us too hard. So with
that Dan please.
>> Thank you. Thank you Gotti.
Uh let's get this up over here.
I can see that. Woohoo. All right.
Great.
Uh so again, thank you for the
introduction. I am Dan Guido. I'm the
CEO and co-founder of Trailabits. Uh and
I'm here to talk about how we made Trail
of Bits AI native so far. It's a
journey. We're not there yet. Um so just
to start out, uh this article came out
about two weeks ago. There were
thousands of CEOs surveyed and the
result was that AI had no measurable
impact on employment or productivity for
them. Uh economists are starting to call
this the solo paradox which is a a
phrase that was coined in the 80s saying
this this economist called uh Robert
Solo that said you can see the computer
age everywhere but in the productivity
statistics. Uh so the same thing is sort
of happening with AI right now that a
lot of people think they're using it and
they find out that it doesn't work and
the projects get dropped. Um so
obviously I don't think AI doesn't work.
Uh I just think most companies are doing
it wrong. uh they give people tools
without changing the system. So everyone
gets a chat GPT license and then
leadership waits for the productivity
numbers to move and they don't. So
that's the gap between AI assisted and
AI native. One is a tool, the other is
an operating system and the rest of this
talk is about how I'm building the
operating system at trailits.
Uh so before I go on um I want to define
what we're even aiming for. So AI native
gets thrown around a lot. It means a lot
of different things. different people
and the way I think about it is that
there are basically three levels. Most
companies start at level one. AI
assisted is where everyone starts. You
give people chat GPT, they draft emails,
generate boilerplate, you know, the
organization doesn't change, the
workflows don't change. You just do the
same things a little faster. Um, AI
augmented is where things start to get
interesting. That's where you start
slowly, incrementally redesigning
workflows. You're not just using AI as a
tool, but you're putting agents in the
loop. You're changing how work actually
flows. and maybe the AI does the first
pass on your code review and then the
human does the second. Uh so the process
is slightly different. And then finally
AI native is where you get to a
structural shift. This is where you've
designed the organization from the
ground up assuming AI is a co-articipant
in the work. It's not a tool. It's a
teammate. And that's your knowledge
management, your delivery model, your
expertise. All of them have to be
designed to be consumed and amplified by
agents. So at Trail of Bits, what this
means is that our security expertise
should compound with code. Every
engagement we do, all the skills, all
the workflows we build make the next
engagement faster. Every engineer
operates with an arsenal of specialized
agents built from our 14 years of audit
knowledge. That's not we use AI, that's
AI is on the team. [snorts]
Uh so candidly, I had a lot of trouble
getting here. Uh when I first launched
this initiative inside Trail of Bits,
there was an incredible amount of push
back. Uh like you would not believe. I
think that I had about 5% of the company
with me, about 95 against um at least
50% were passively resisting. There were
probably a good quarter that were
actively resisting. Um I'm sure people
thought about quitting. Just totally
like cards on the table here. Um and
this isn't really an uncommon issue.
Whenever new technology comes around,
people resist adopting it. And it can be
the most senior, most expert people that
resist the most. So I had to work
through a couple of common psychological
barriers that are well documented in
research and build systems that worked
within those psychological conditions to
get to success. The the core insight
here is the problem's not the
technology, it's the people. So um these
are four uh psychological barriers
that um that are I think key among all
the other ones in getting people to
adopt new technology inside of a company
like Trail Bits. First was
self-enhancing bias. This is the
tendency to perceive oneself in an
overly favorable manner. Uh so you
obviously want to maintain your own
self-esteem and this bias means that you
take credit for your success and you
blame external factors on failures. Um,
now there are some funny interactions
with this. Like in in some research by
uh Paul Meal and Robin Daw, you can take
the variables an expert says they use
and build a crude linear model and the
model outperforms the expert almost
always. And it's not because the model
is smarter. It's because it's
consistent. Humans don't operate the
same every day. Some of you are very
hung over right now and I'm sure you
could agree with me on this. Um, and
this gets worse with seniority. the the
more that you are an expert, the more
that you believe that your intuition is
what got you there. Uh there's also an
identity threat. This really attacks the
core of who we are. That like I spent 20
years doing this. A machine can't can't
do 20 years of experience and like it
get to be me. Um and this shows up in in
things like uh there there was Stanford
ran a cooking study. They they they use
this device, some cooking system, and
they advertised it two different ways.
One way is it does the cooking for you.
The other way is it helps you cook
better. And uh it's the same device, but
for people who identify as cooks, they
reject the device if it's advertised the
first way. There's another dimension to
this as well based on the the symbolism
of what the activity represents. So for
instance, if you had a tattoo robot,
people do not want tattoo do not want
robots to give them tattoos because it's
symbolic. There's a human craft to it.
but they're fine with a tattoo removing
one because that's an instrumental
process. There's no symbolism there. So
for us, security auditing is deeply
symbolic work and it's important to
frame the AI as making you a more
dangerous auditor, not something that
does the audit.
Uh there's also challenges in opacity.
Uh so in this case, the subjective
understanding of human judgment is high
and AI judgment is low, but objectively
you actually understand neither. Um,
like when a doctor tries to communicate
to you that you might have some medical
condition or cancer or something, you
might think you understand the words
that are coming out of their mouth, but
you absolutely do not. Um, but the level
of trust you have in the doctor is way
higher than if a machine just prints out
a receipt and says, "Here's what you
got." So, the way you typically fix this
is, uh, you could modify the same AI to
show you, uh, well, why is this not a
benign, uh, skin condition? uh and if
you give a visual comparison to a benign
mole then trust starts to equalize. So
we had to think about how to build this
into our process as well. And then
finally humans have an intolerance for
imperfection. Uh so again well-known
academic study participants watch an
algorithm outperform a human forecaster.
The algorithm is better but the second
that the algorithm makes a single error
humans switch back to preferring the
human. Um the fix in this case is
generally to let people modify the
algorithm. If they have the perception
of control then they start to trust the
process again.
So what did we do?
Uh so for the self-enhancing bias uh we
built a maturity matrix. Uh this was
controversial internally. Nobody likes
being told they're at level one but
that's the point. You can't argue with
something that you're you can't argue
that you're good enough when there's a
visible ladder. And it also makes the
conversation concrete instead of I don't
think AI is useful. Uh it also creates
social proof. When you see your peers
escalating up the ladder, the passive
50% of the company starts to move with
them. Uh the identity threat was
extremely difficult. You had to get
people to accept skill allowing
automations and reject skill replacing
automation. Same tool, different
framing. So we never really asked anyone
well we not never really we didn't ever
ask anyone to stop being a security
expert but we gave them a different way
to express that identity. So the skills
repos that I hope you all are familiar
with are the clearest example of that.
When we have a senior consultant on the
team write a constant time analysis
skill. They're not being replaced.
They're becoming permanent inside the
company. And that means their expertise
is encoded and reusable by the whole
team. That's an identity upgrade, not a
threat. So the maturity matrix
reinforces this. Level three isn't who
uses AI the most. It's who invents new
ways and builds new tools. So the
identity shifts from I don't need AI to
I'm the one who makes AI dangerous. Uh
we also did hackathons instead of
mandates. I never forced anyone to adopt
these tools, but we created a space
where people could experiment on their
own terms. Uh oh, I'm not doing that.
There we go. [snorts]
um for the intolerance for imperfection.
Uh everyone if if if somebody's first
experience with AI is bad, you've lost
them for months. Uh so one error and
people just abandon the system. So we
invested a lot in ways to reduce the
ways that AI can fail embarrassingly. We
cured a marketplace so that people
weren't getting random plugins. We
created sandboxing tools so Claude Code
didn't accidentally delete your work. uh
we put guard rails and footgun reduction
systems in place so that there were a
lot less of like you know AI did
something stupid stories circulating in
Slack. Uh for opacity we clearly
articulated what tools were allowed and
which ones were not and under what
conditions. We described those
conditions and why we why we decided to
uh adopt those risk levels. And then we
made adoption fast and visible. So this
really underpins everything else. If the
setup takes an hour and the first result
is mediocre, then you've confirmed
everyone's priors.
So we have copypastable configurations,
one command setup, we have a
standardized tool chain and the first
experience is fast and good. And then I
think finally
I matter to this more than most people
think. Uh the passive 50% of the company
is going to watch what leadership
actually does, not what it says. So if
I'm using these tools visibly every
single day, it signals that it's not a
fad. We're actually allin.
So that's the problem and the approach.
Uh here's the actual system we built. So
five parts. Each one addresses barriers
we just talked about. I'm going to walk
through each of these in detail with
screenshots and examples. Uh but this is
the overview. You could think of it like
a checklist. Uh but you need all five
for it to compound. And um importantly,
this isn't like some strategy deck that
like I'm presenting here. This is
everything that we built ourselves and
most of it has been open sourced so that
all of you can use it right now. Uh this
is what I use for a 140 person company
doing real client work. So let's go
through each one. Uh first one, super
boring. We had to standardize. Uh we got
everybody on cloud code and we treat it
like any other enterprise tool. We have
supported configs, no good defaults, and
a clear path to this is how we do it
here. If you skip this step, you can't
build anything else because you end up
with 40 different workflows and zero
leverage on it. So, for better or for
worse, we settled on cloud code. I think
it was for better.
Uh, next thing we wrote an AI handbook.
And this wasn't to teach people how to
prompt, but it was to remove ambiguity.
What tools are approved and what isn't,
especially for sensitive data where we
have a lot of that. So, we explicitly
call things out like where a tool can't
be used on client code, where meeting
recorders are disallowed depending on
engagement type, where we want people to
use a specific alternative. And that
stops the endless Slack debates. It
gives project managers and engineers a
shared answer, and it makes client
conversations consistent. When we have
highly sensitive clients ask us
questions about, hey, what are you using
on the code that you I I've given you? I
can give them a clear answer that
everybody knows. So once you have a
policy, you can push harder on adoption.
Then I will I will post this on Twitter
because no one can read it. Uh but we
built an AI maturity matrix. Um this
makes AI a firstass professional
capability. It's just the same as you
can use git or you can write tests or
you can audit C. It's not a vibe. It's a
ladder. So there are clear levels. There
are expectations for getting one for
escalating uh and there are consequences
for staying stuck. It starts at level
zero and if you're stuck at level zero
and you're not engaged in this process
then there may be uh transition out of
the company. Um and this is how you
avoid two different failure modes. You
don't want leadership to like wish
adoption into existence and you don't
want the organization splitting into AI
people verse everybody else. This is a
whole company need. Everybody needs to
be on board. So this turns it into a
normal part of performance growth,
resource allocation,
uh and and bonuses.
Um now the fun part. So hackathons,
hackathons became a management system
for us. We run short focused sprints,
two to three days with a specific
objective, one objective, and that's how
we keep pace when the ecosystem changes
every single week. So here's one of the
kickoffs for one of them. Uh we did this
one or actually well these are both
these are the last two I think. Uh which
one I think the one on the right is um
our autonomy focused one. Uh the most
important thing is that we put a
constraint on the hackathon. You had to
run clawed code and bypass permissions
mode. This was to break the barrier on
people's hesitance to giving full
control over the tools and build systems
that allow it to work under those
constraints. So that was intentional. It
forces everyone to learn how to use
sandboxing guard rails and how to
structure their work so that the agents
can succeed on their own.
Um other design choices that we made, we
focus on public repositories so that we
can move fast and show real outcomes. Um
we measured success on activity. I
wanted people to put in the reps. So
we're talking about issues fixed and
filed, PRs reviewed and merged, branches
created and deleted. uh we're not so
worried about like the meaning behind
all that code. I just want activities
that they put in the reps. Uh and then
we had people work in pairs. Every
change gets reviewed by a buddy. Uh so
even with the move fast uh sort of
sprint style work, we had some quality
control built in. So the hackathons
create motion, but the motion doesn't
compound unless you capture it.
And that's where we started collecting
these artifacts as skills. Uh so a skill
most of you know is a reusable
structured workflow uh usually with
examples constraints and a way to verify
the output. So we maintain three
separate skills repos uh two of which
you all have access to. Uh we have an
internal one that has a lot of company
specific workflows and a lot of our most
sensitive vulnerability research related
skills but we also have an external one
so that the broader community can
validate and improve on the work that
we're doing. Uh the third one is we have
a curated marketplace which I think I'm
talking about next. Yeah. So for a firm
like ours um I appreciate the external
validation. It keeps us honest and it
forces us to write things that other
people can actually use. That's a core
value of trail bits. I don't want to
just release a black hat talk that gets
me a wired article or whatever and
disappear the next day. We measure
success based on uh downloads of a
specific tool or stars of a specific
tool. I want continued usage um and uh
and enhancement.
So then we have another problem. You
know, you tell people to go use skills
and plugins and they go use skills and
plugins and they get a whole bunch of
random stuff that's like AI slop filled
with emojis and uh you know steals your
cryptocurrency.
Um so we created a curated marketplace
and this is just standard you know
enterprise stuff, right? We made a known
good place for third party skills. you
want a third party skill, there's a
command built into the curated
marketplace that goes out and grabs it
from somewhere else, filters it, and
then puts it into ours. Uh, so if you
want adoption, you need to save supply
chain.
Basic enterprise thinking.
Uh, then we made the defaults dead
simple. So after we went through a
couple of rounds of this, we started to
get to a really like known good um trail
of bits style clawed code installation.
So we publish a repository that has our
recommended cla code configuration. I
want to eliminate tribal knowledge. We
want to have specifics around this is
how we do claude code at trail of bits.
So we put known good settings a known
good cloud.mmd and anything else that we
want to standardize for how people use
it. We also included some usage
instructions there. Um now this is
freely available but there is a whole
separate section that describes how to
use it for bug hunting that we're we're
keeping internal. So if you're wondering
where that part is, uh that's why it's
missing. So it's very developer focused.
Um then the real constraint obviously
the more control that you give to these
agents, you're going to want a sandbox.
Uh so we give people choices. We don't
just tell people to do one thing or
enforce the clawed built-in sandbox,
which is quite good. Um but we give
people choices and we invested in
building some of our own. We built a dev
container option. We made um another one
that uh uh automatically interacts with
digital ocean to create single-use
virtual machines in the cloud. And then
we documented the native Mac OS
sandboxing option. So the point wasn't
that everybody uses the same sandbox.
The point is that everyone has a safe
sandbox to use. You know, we have a
variety of different things going under
one roof at Trail of Bits. We have
engineering engagements, research
engagements, audits, we have
nontechnical staff, operations staff,
and they all need different solutions. I
can't mandate one.
Uh then as you give people more
autonomy, these agents start to go
haywire in different ways. They start to
pull in third party dependencies that
have security issues. So the one step
that we took that I think uh is is
extraordinarily effective besides the
ignore scripts in uh npm was implement a
mandatory developer uh mandatory package
cooldown policy. So, nobody installs
packages that are less than seven days
old for any package manager across the
company. We have it enforced with MDM.
Um, that's the I think the easiest way
to reduce risk and make the safe path
the default path. There's more that
we've done here, but this is something
that I'm preparing to release. We're
going to start open sourcing our entire
uh JF configuration stack for how we
secure some of these agents with MDM.
Uh and then finally, once you have the
policies, the guardrails, the sandboxes,
the skills, you can connect agents to
real tools. Uh so one example that we've
already wrapped inside of an MCP server
is Slither. Um and if you don't care
about Slither, which is a static
analyzer for Ethereum smart contracts,
the point is that MCP turns your
internal tools into something that
agents can use reliably and that your
org can govern.
Uh so this is another way that we can
inject policy into how these tools get
used.
Um, so now the results. So, um, you
know, you've seen some of our open
source work, but internally I can share
that we have 94 separate plugins
accumulating 2014
specialized agents and 400 reference
files encoding all of our domain
expertise. And that's the compounding
effect. So every single engagement,
every auditor, every experiment adds to
that arsenal. And what's important is
the breath, right? We're not just
talking about an auditing toolkit. I
have skills for writing sales proposals,
tracking project hours, onboarding new
hires, prepping conference blog posts.
Uh we have 20 plus plugin plugins
targeting specific vulnerability
classes. Um but uh you know each the
important thing is each package um each
one packages expertise that used to live
in somebody's head and it turns into
something that every auditor on the team
can now invoke. On the delivery side, uh
we have certain clients where the
codebase and the scope allow it. We've
gone from finding 15 bugs a week to
finding 200 bugs per week. And that's
not a faster human. That's an auditor
running a fleet of specialized
engagements that do targeted analysis
across the codebase in parallel and then
validate the results. So across most of
our engagements at Trail of Bits, the
number that we're about at is that 20%
of all the bugs we report to our clients
were initially discovered by AI.
Um on the business side, we also have
our sales team averaging about $8
million in revenue per representative,
which is about double what the industry
averages for uh for sales for sales
consulting. Um so yeah so AI doesn't
just help our engineers it also helps
with proposal drafting competitive
positioning conference prep lead
enrichment uh same system same
repositories same compounding effect
uh and this is maybe you know a year
into building the system seriously cloud
code came out what was about a year ago
um the models get better every month the
skills grow every week and a year from
now these numbers are going to look very
Uh yeah.
So let me close with some of the
essential starter path. This is the
minimum viable AI native org design. Uh
this is what we've done so far and it's
changed how fast we can ship and how
quickly we adapt. If you want to copy
this, you have to copy the system, not
the tools.
Uh we do have some open questions. You
know, there's obviously some things
we're still working on. Um, obviously,
uh, Gotti made an illusion to a
conversation I had with him about
private inference. Um, you know, we
don't want to always send our queries to
the cloud. Sometimes we want to do them
on a machine that we control. But, uh,
these local models, they're good, but
they're not amazing. There's definitely
this big model smell where you can tell
the difference between, you know, Opus
46 and a Haiku 46, uh, no matter what
day it is. Um, so right now we're
investigating a couple of paths here and
I'm sort of reticent to spend money on a
local server because a lot of the
private inference systems are getting
really good. Uh, we've been evaluating
tinfoil.sh, but there's a huge variety
of other private inference servers that
are now available where I can
confidentially run my queries in
somebody else's cloud. So these are
where um, you know, we're doing some
research to figure out the right
solution for us. The prompt injection
problem obviously not solved. we have a
real blunt instrument for solving it
today, which is for certain clients, we
just deny access to the web. Uh, and for
a lot of our internal tools, we don't
allow them access to external resources.
Um, so things we're playing with here
are agent native shells. We're looking
at things like the no shell, agentsh
that are going to wrap the agent
execution in something that can be
protected with uh, kernel level system
calls instead of, you know,
discretionary guidance thrown into a
claw. MD. Uh, and then something else we
don't have solved yet is policy
enforcement and continuous learning. So,
we push a lot of settings via MDM, but
what do we get back? Because there's a
huge amount of data that's accumulated
on each person's device about how
they're actually using AI and how
they're doing their job that I would
love to be able to collect and
synthesize and use to enhance our
process. And we don't have a solution
there yet either, but it's something we
will probably soon. uh you can take a
look at things from trail bits like our
we audit visual studio code extension
that might offer a solution there. Um
you know longer term we also need some
sort of policy architecture. You can see
stripe with their minions paper they
have one giant MCP server that all their
agents call into and that they can use
to enforce policy and that might be a
good long-term answer. And then finally
the business is really shifting. I think
consulting today may not last that long.
uh we're looking at billing by hours
today, but in a future where everybody
has an arsenal of agents and some people
can outperform others by 200x, I think
you have to start billing by expertise
and by results. So the nature of how
Trail of Bits offers our services to the
world is probably going to change in the
next 6 to 12 months as well. And again,
no answers there yet because we're still
on this journey just like everyone else.
Uh so I wanted to offer a few links to
these references. These are all the
tools that I talked about during this
talk. I also want to mention that
yesterday as a gift to you all I open
source 10 additional plugins. Uh we have
one for checking false positives for
bugs that your claude might find and you
want to give it the ability to check. We
have a fun one called let fate decide
that teaches your agent how to deal
tarot cards. Um, as well as a whole
bunch of others that are up on my
Twitter and that are up in the skills
repo right now. Uh, and then I I would
also be remissed to mention we have a
bunch of jobs open and I would love it
for someone to work with me to carry
this exact process forward. If you want
to help me continue to instrument trail
of bits and make us uh further along in
this journey, uh, please contact me.
Thanks. Thanks, Dan.
All right, we'll we'll uh try to get
back on track here. So, I'll take time
for two questions. Do we have two
questions in the audience? Processing
all of the things to do with an orb.
We've got one over here, Andrew. I'll
run it.
>> Hey, thanks so much. That was amazing.
I'm wondering if an additional um uh
hesitance uh that you've uh seen with
your employees in adopting AI is also
around uh eventually like being replaced
or like mass joblessness, stuff like
that.
>> Yeah. So I think Trail of Bits is in a
really good spot because we're kind of
um I think the term is obeliskshaped.
You know, consulting agencies, they
usually have a really large base of
junior employees and uh I think as
people get more enhanced by AI, it's a
lot of the most senior people that
benefit the most. So I'm going to
sidestep that question and just say that
everybody at Trail of Bits is perfectly
positioned to take advantage of this
because we only have senior level and up
people. Um, I Yeah, I'll leave it there.
[laughter]
>> Civilence. Okay, thanks Dan. Um, uh, I
have a question in terms of like the
blessed lists that you're creating for
the team. How do you think about like
rug pulling attacks or you know what
we've seen with some folks who are like
you know releasing sort of safe and
secure and then updating it with like
some type of you know something
malicious as you think about you know
these are our bless lists are you
checking them every day or how do you
think about
>> bless lists of what of
>> like your MCPs or skills that you've got
or you know any of those
>> oh yeah I mean well we're importing all
of them into an allow list like the only
plugins that you're allowed to use for
trail bits are the verified ones that
are in our curated repo
Uh so we don't want you to install
random skills from other places. If it
gets updated, it gets updated through us
and we have a bunch of automated systems
that help us perform those updates with
speed. So obviously like if something
comes out on Twitter, you want to use it
that minute. Uh but we've enabled the
organization to uh perform those you
know internal update steps on its own.
So our our curated skills repo is open
source. Everybody at Trailabits has
right access to it. uh requires pull
request reviews and it includes um
commands that Cloud Code can understand
to go out and grab those resources. So
you can just give it a tweet and say,
"Hey, I want this." And it goes pulls it
in, tags somebody for review, and then
five minutes later, you've got it on
your machine.
>> Very cool.
>> Cool.
>> Yep. Thank you so much.